you may have forgotten with all the
riots and plague and chaos in the news
there's a presidential campaign going on
I know the mainstream media certainly
wants you to forget about that well
joining us right now to help us remember
that campaign and figure out exactly
where it's headed amid all these
shenanigans we have the great the man
the myth the legend Donald Trump jr.
executive VP at the Trump Organization
and the number one New York Times
bestselling author of the book triggered
how the left thrives on hate and wants
to silence us every word of that
absolutely true mr. Trump thank you so
much for coming on so I think people are
beginning to remember we're in this
presidential election campaign the media
had been distracting us with a whole lot
of nonsense but we're getting into it
now Joe Biden just gave this kind of sad
press briefing where he invited people
and he he more or less announced he was
not going to campaign he's not going to
hold rallies the New York Times is
publishing op eds on why Joe Biden
probably shouldn't debate do you think
from from your vantage right now that
Biden is gonna try to weasel out of some
of these debates I think without
question I mean you know I've heard this
obviously I live in New York I have some
friends that sorta intersect with a lot
of the liberal circles I've heard the
rumors about hey they're gonna try to
come up with an excuse because the
reality is they don't want you Oh Biden
on the stage with Donald Trump okay you
saw what happened to seven teen seasoned
Republicans last time you saw what
happened to Hillary Clinton last time
you know Joe Biden doesn't know where he
is fifty percent of the time they don't
want their him to be on the stage they
will do whatever they can for him you
see that the media has totally abdicated
their responsibility to look into not
only you know Biden's clear and obvious
cognitive issues that they had no
problem
assessing Trump they just stop talking
about it once Trump took a cognitive
test and literally aced it right you
know Biden literally the other day it's
Ted
he has taken numerous cognitive tests he
takes them all the time Michael why
would you need to take a cognitive test
all the time I mean you know that we're
pretending
that Joe Biden's going to be the guy
that's going to be in charge if he wins
this presidential race is scary what I
believe is going to happen is if he wins
the left and the uber left and that
crazy people in the Democratic Party are
going to be the leaders you see what
they're saying whether it's the fund the
police whether it's destroyed Mount
Rushmore they're not even joking anymore
and the media is carrying the order no
no defund the police doesn't really mean
defund the police it's like a theory and
that ASP has to put out a press release
no no the bleeds actually means defund
the police like what are you guys
talking about right I mean it is it's
truly laughable right that's that's true
I think some people are trying to
portray Joe Biden is some kind of
radical he's no radical he's an empty
suit who as you point out now forgets
his own name and whatever people think
about the president you know ever they
think about your father
the guy is in his own words youthful and
vibrant you know the guy he goes for
hours and these rallies and he's clearly
I think would be very bad for Joe Biden
if he were to get on a debate stage with
him so I agree with you I think they're
gonna try to ditch those debates but the
trouble is so far this strategy has
succeeded just by coincidence it seems
that the media have been able to keep
Joe out of the spotlight he would be
making 50 gaffes a day but he's not
because he's permitted to hide in his
basement and he's saying that it's
because of the public health and he's so
worried about everybody's health it's
just the doctor's orders so what do you
think we know they want to cancel the
campaign we know they're pushing
widespread mail-in ballots huge
potential for voter fraud they're
guaranteed voter fraud there and they're
hiding Biden in the basement do you
think the country needs to reopen in
order for the president to get reelected
you know III think we need to see some
progress towards that you know the
reality you see this the New York Times
or one of these big articles today was
well just because deaths are down
tenfold that's not really good news as
it relates because that's you know I'm
like wait really right it's not like you
know they are doing whatever they can to
help Joe Biden they the reality is
there's never been a political campaign
in modern history not just American
history where the people running it are
we have to do what
we can to hide our candidate from the
people who would be his constituents
right we have to hide him from the voter
now the media is more than happy to do
that because they know once you get Joe
Biden on the stage you these aren't gaps
anymore Michael either they all show by
just always go back and watch a video of
Joe Biden 20 years ago
yeah it's not the same guy yeah so we
can pretend it's a gap we can pretend
it's this but there is real cognitive
decline you know I want to know where
all the television psychologists that
you know for years said you know Trump's
in the later stages of dementia and
Alzheimer's combined where are they on
Joe Biden because they're eerily silent
on something that is literally a hundred
x-rite whatever they could have possibly
said about Trump to the point where I
mean you see people like uh well you
know hey god that's rough okay well
maybe we just won't talk about that one
the media is acting as a left-wing
activist organization doing whatever
they can to protect you Biden and it's
not just you know well is he a moderate
if he erratic 'el he's flip-flopped on
every position he's ever had in his
entire career that yeah well the one
nice thing about Kovac 19 was that for
four months a quarantine I could
actually look into some of these things
and you look at his actual record more
importantly other than the terrible
record on racial issues and everything
like that his economic record I mean
he's literally responsible for China
growing into the behemoth that it is
with his policies that helped them get
into the World Trade Organization help
them skirt all the loss I mean he
literally turned China from a economy
the size of the Netherlands to the
behemoth that it is today with stupid
policies if he knew how to fix race
issues if he knew how to fix the economy
why didn't he do it mama
bingo why didn't he do it in 50 years in
Washington DC 50 years you make it seem
like he runs on the campaign of well you
know Washington DC has failed you it's
like yes I'm with you in this one show
but maybe you're part of that problem
you've been there for 50 years he's not
blue-collar Joe he's never had a job
outside of Washington DC it's nonsense
to me this is the whole key done you've
completely hit on it which is China I
know some some people are going after by
now on race I mean he has said some
pretty colorful things on the question
of race or they're going
after him because he had the 90 for
crime bill but frankly I think a lot of
conservatives actually would like people
to get tough on crime so to me those are
all good things to hit him on absolute
you know it's a political campaign but
the key is China and it works on two
different levels because there's the
international component China just
destroyed our economy they Unleashed
this virus on us they lied about it they
bought off the w-h-o which thankfully
your father just pulled us out of so
we're no longer in that farce of an
organization but they did this right and
Joe Biden the whole way was applauding
it he said a rising China is good for
everybody
there were a lot of Republicans who
agreed with that too but early on the
president your father said this is a bad
idea don't do it and it ties in with
with blue-collar and middle class jobs
too because so much of the outsourcing
so much of losing our manufacturing ties
in with this issue of rising China is
that going to be a central issue of the
campaign I mean is there any way to hit
Biden on it where where the media won't
just cover for him well they'll always
just covering for him but we just got to
hit him anyway the reality is you know
you hit the nail on the head if we've
learned one thing from Kovac 19 it's
that China's not our friend yeah China's
not the friend of the world China's
gonna do what's right for China we've
seen that for decades my father's been
talking about it for decades it was the
impetus or at least one of the big ones
of him actually running if you look at
what there used to be a pin tweet on my
Twitter profile of him on Oprah in like
1986 talking about stupid trade deals
our only export Michael for the last 50
years has been the American dream we've
given China the ability to live the
American dream because of politicians
like Joe Biden and their stupid policies
okay so if there's one thing we've
learned is we got a pushback on China
who's gonna do that the guy that
literally has quotes for decades being
soft on China allowing for their rise
the crew you know putting them into the
World Trade Organization all of these
things and a guy whose son got 1.5
billion dollars from the Chinese
government I'm sure the media would have
no problem with it if I got that you
know only 30 million dollars a year in
fees in a typical fund structure right
minor minor detail you know they'd have
no problem with it you think Joe Biden's
going to be tough on China or do you
think the one
American politician who has taken on
China and more importantly because in
2016 it was a promise actually got
something dug as what was it January 15
beside the trade deal with China yeah
save some of our IP yeah you know puts
restrictions on their ability to
manipulate the systems which they've
been doing and we've turned a blind eye
to for decades yep the guy that actually
did it once he's the guy that could do
it again same with the economy you know
if Joe Biden knew how to fix the economy
why didn't he tell Obama yeah he doesn't
know how to fix the economy he has no
clue he's never worked in an economy
he's just been a politician for 50 years
in Washington DC Donald Trump created an
economy where there was not a single
economic metric where we were not better
off than we were under the prior
administration by the way those numbers
actually continue to this day despite a
worldwide pandemic that should tell you
something right you know I'm sick of
being lectured by these academics who've
never done it nothing about it never
signed the front of a paycheck yet they
know everything yes a results have been
disastrous for America yeah we finally
have someone that's actually delivering
for America we shouldn't change that and
that's a powerful line you mentioned
which is for the past 50 years our only
export has been the American dream and
you know that that's good for everybody
else around the world but what have we
been importing instead as we've given
away our manufacturing as we've as we've
destroyed the American dream for a great
many of our own citizens what have we
been importing cheap consumer goods and
apparently about crap that breaks in
about two days yes that's right that's
what we've gotten out of this trade yeah
it's nonsense it hasn't been right you
know the notion 50 years ago may have
made sense you know maybe if we helped
build up China a little bit maybe
they'll become like us guess what boys
and girls China ain't becoming like us
yeah I mean is China and the dictatorial
regime that everyone pretends is so
wonderful like the NBA oh they're so
great you know because they want the
money yeah they're not so great
okay but we were under the misguided
misconception that we would be able to
get them to turn into us we got to give
up that notion that's why even some
Republicans are weak on this issue that
they're still going with like a 1980s
yep you know policy or well maybe
they'll become like us if we if we just
pretend that they're not taking total
advantage of us we
destroyed our country we've seeded 200
years of hegemony because we were stupid
because we had decision-makers that had
no business making these kind of
decision we finally have someone in
there that's doing it that's actually
getting it done not just talking because
we hear that a lot from politicians but
someone who's actually getting it done
and you're going to give Joe Biden a
chance to run I mean it's it's sort of
asinine right right Raavi this this I
think is actually this may be your
father's most significant and long
lasting legacy is that he has dispelled
so many of these ridiculous illusions
illusions on building up China and
that's gonna be great for everybody and
not no consequences for Americans
illusions on the media being objective
you know he's just come in there and
given a healthy dose of reality which I
love he did this on the question of
history the other day at that Mount
Rushmore speech which I thought like I
not only did I breathe a sigh of relief
I like cheered it because I thought yes
this is what the campaign should be
doing this is exactly what the president
should be saying I wish we heard it
years ago from other politicians too but
I'll take it now and if this guy says
this kind of thing every single day
until the election he's gonna win in a
landslide can we expect more of these
rallies I know the media is trying to
shut them down
but are we gonna get a real campaign
here we're gonna get some real rallies
you're obviously going to see you know
you know more of it you know it for us
it's a catch-22 right I mean if someone
gets hit by a bus they'll say it's
covert 19 - William Trump right we
literally cannot win in in these
situations but you do have to see it you
do have to take the message to the
American people by close by you know I
follow your feet I see what you do like
we're all a combined but we also live
this stuff at this point 24/7 yeah for
the average American who's consuming
five or ten minutes of news a day and
it's 96% negative against Trump yep even
before you know Corona despite
unprecedented economic success despite
all-time low unemployment numbers for
every minority group in the country and
in literally everything that they would
anoint Obama Emperor for life before
Trump actually did it's like nothing to
see here folks you know go away so we
have to recognize you know again that
the media is not on our side they are
not
fair arbiters in this decision they've
become activists that's all they want to
do and you know that's not a small thing
to combat I mean they will literally
give Joe Biden billions yeah in free
cover up right for right abject
stupidity you know any benefit of the
doubt he will be given we will be
exactly the opposite of a doubt it's
obviously going to be not optimist razor
it's going to be the opposite you're
going to be the point oh-o-oh 1% chance
for something actually beating that
that's what 100% that's what they're
going for that's right and it's why you
know I think we always hear this that
this is the most important election of
our lifetimes blah blah blah well let me
tell you when they're tearing down
statues of George Washington and
literally setting the country on fire
for their far-left ideology the stakes
are very very high I think that the
statement might be true we're out of
time
Don thank you so much for coming on a
really appreciated best of luck to you
all my best to KITT kimberly guilfoyle
as she combats the virus and best of
luck to of course to your father and the
campaign
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description